couldn't play a video as a director as
an Android application of course you
already mentioned one of them which is
to go ahead and open up the the native
YouTube application you can do that feat
intent and that's definitely a good
approach but the downside there is that
it's going to take you out of your
application and so if you're looking for
a more immersive experience you have a
few other options you could go ahead and
add a webview with which links to the
flash version to youtube or you could
also go and load the html5 version of
YouTube the catch each of those have
some catches though pretty important
older devices and actually some newer
devices that matter to don't have flash
installed so the flash player is not
always available and all the devices
aren't going to be able to play you on
video or html5 video unless they have an
html5 compliant webview implementation
so with that that other way that the
current devices that pretty much limits
your options to the built-in YouTube app
so for almost all practical purposes
right now I'd say the best option is to
go ahead and fire off intent and send
the user off to the YouTube player just
so they have the best YouTube playback
experience now that's it we did
pre-announced a YouTube API for Android
at Google i/o this year it's not ready
yet but it will be at some point in the
future and that allow you to go ahead
and embed YouTube videos within your
application just as a you know basically
like the way webview works except it'll
be a YouTube view so if you want to
learn more about that go ahead and
search google for YouTube Android API
and there's a slide deck and they
actually a video on youtube for that
matter where you go ahead and learn more
about all that and yeah keep an ad that
for some time later the near future I
don't know an exact date but sometime
hopefully soon there'll be some more
more news on that and if you want a demo
actually the google i/o app the android
scheduled appt is a good example of how
that works here's a actually an
interesting question i don't know the
answer this myself but is it possible to
detect at runtime if there is if the
phone will support you to be a flash
that's a good question I imagine you can
actually check the Paycheck package
manager and
for the flash package if you see that on
there is probably a pretty good time
flash is working right see what I would
suggest maybe is because the poster
Michelle does state that she would
prefer to keep the user inside the app
is if there's a way to detect if at
runtime if flash is supported on the
device or if you TV html5 would be
support on the device it would require
extra effort but you could just
implement do all three implementations
and say okay flash is supported on this
device do it in flash if not if html5
support on this device you can embedded
web view if not intent out that way you
would have a wider range of phones that
you support for a nap and not
necessarily have to go to the YouTube
app every time yep now I've seen some
people use our TSP also but i'm not i'm
not sure if that's actually allowed so
you might want to check the youtube
terms of service i sort of had
suspicions that you might not be allowed
to do that better we really hurt we
discourage sketchy behavior right I
going TOS issues aside even though they
are they are real issues but if you do
something like that it is liable to get
broken in the next version of android
once a security fix for this is
determined i don't think that's a
security issue you're not secure I think
that's just a YouTube terms of service
issue yeah but any case I think the
correct enter here until we get that the
YouTube API out is to go ahead and use
the embed their the native YouTube app I
think that's for pretty much every case
there you're going to get the best
experience that way but yeah at least
for now so let's go ahead and move on to
the next question I just rest then we
never turn on the lights in here
makes it we can make that happen yeah
all right let's move on to the next
question all right next question a real
bluetooth headset button push still
works in the foreground music app but my
mimicked action media button intense no
longer work in android 4.0 or above as i
said the google music hogs them what are
bluetooth headsets doing differently
excellent question so this question i
think just came in probably about 10
minutes before a broadcast yeah we
unfortunately have not had time to
research it and neither of us I think
know off the top of our heads yeah I
it's possible to this being hint you
know that the the media APR the media
framework is going in the loo and
integrating the right clothes the
Bluetooth stack I'm not actually sure
the good news is the source is out there
if you want to go ahead and take a look
you know you can go ahead dig a little
deeper will do the same on our end try
and get you an answer for the next show
again we just don't have enough time
that we didn't have enough time before
to actually get research and the answer
here yeah I think trying to mimic the
action media button intent to simulate a
Bluetooth button push is a little
sketchy so I'm not terribly surprised
that you're having some issues there but
we'll try and get you an answer try and
figure out what's going on join us next
week and we'll have an answer for you at
the beanie of the show all right we just
got brighter it did yeah right takes
away my ominous shadowy appearance all
right so is there a reason why Google
does not release updates of new Android
versions for all interested developers
with Nexus 7 and Galaxy Nexus devices
right away outside of the long OTA cycle
without having to root the device and
doing it manually yeah and that's by
Chris from London um oh I I think it's
actually a valid point I was austral
yeah so right now the way we do software
updates assuming you how the device that
has a update available is we roll the
device out to a fraction of users at a
time and there's a number of reasons we
do that first off it makes sure that we
don't overload carrier networks for
people who are on
cellular connections in fact I think
there's even an option in there where
they can go and offer it only to Wi-Fi
users for the first you know 24 or 48
hours but we also go and roll out slowly
to just to make sure that if there's
need bugs with the update major major
bugs that somehow we didn't catch during
testing then we can go ahead and abort
the update and solve those problems
before many users are impacted now we do
testings pretty thoroughly and it's rare
that something like that happens it's
just a safety device that we basically
built in I think in the case of
developers this is a valid concern it
will be definitely very nice to be one
of the first users to get a software
update so that way you can update your
application so I'll make sure that the
actually I think that we already filed a
bug this morning for this so there is a
bug open we'll go ahead and make sure
that the OTA team sees it as a feature
request I think it's completely about
and thank you for the great idea we'll
see what we can do to get that that
implemented for you yeah all right so
okay when will we get a supported
marketplace API EG to search the
marketplace for apps and pull their
details screen shots and analyze
comments and ratings microsoft and apple
support this and they and they are
closed markets that's a good question
unfortunately this definitely falls
under the category of roadmap question
and as a matter of policy or we can't
discuss future future features that we
may or may not be implementing or
whether or not we're working on them
when the you know hypothetically state
would be that kind of thing we will
definitely follow it as a feature
request but we can't really say anything
about when it when it would happen or if
we're working on it yep I think that's a
pretty good answer so prizzy from the
Philippines says can i retrieve data
from the google maps api so i can use it
for my location based services
application i'm developing so i'm not
sure what sort of data you're looking
for a pressie but there are a number of
things that you can access already you
can access the users current location
via the location manager that's actually
really doesn't have anything to do
with Google Maps it's just what's the
users latitude longitude altitude basic
data you get from GPS or if there's a
Wi-Fi network nearby it can do course
location things like that you can also
do geocoding which is actually I think
it's reverse geocode that's it no its
energy I Cody oh yeah so it's converting
latitude and longitude to a a human
readable address you know that's reverse
geocoding okay now do we did good yeah i
think we support both ways okay i
believe we support both ways those
actually might be via the Maps API
actually space via location manager
interest I think it uses maps under the
hood but it is part of the location
manager package so there's utilities to
go and convert from lifelong to address
and back from a tour still at long so
that's all totally possible now if you
want to do something more graphical
right you want to display a map and let
the user see you know where they are in
the world as opposed to just telling
them their new maker numerical address
right you can embed a map view inside of
your application which will render
Google Maps the location and there's
some limited options to go and customize
that if you want to go a step further
and start adding really complicated
stuff like polygons markers markers
custom map tiles you can go ahead and
add a web view that loads the google
maps api from the web and that's how you
can get some of those advanced features
we definitely encourage people to use a
standard map view at first but you know
sometimes you do want to do these
advanced things and that's when you have
to look into the web based api's so i
think that's a yes as far as the answer
to this question now if you want to do
something like get driving directions
though that's where you're going to run
into some problems and you won't be able
to pull that data out to add a google
maps but I believe you can send the user
yeah you can totally just send the user
over to google maps and you know
construct the URL for directions and
have that load so there are ways to go
and tell Google Maps what data you'd
like it to display but it'll still be
within google maps of these are
receiving that content
I also want to add we do have a lot of
online resources for using the Maps API
with Android it's on
developer.android.com / android i don't
remember the tail end of their you are a
developer die enjoyed that complex re
developer google com / android there you
go and that's where most of the API is
for using google services with android
that's where you're going to find those
alright so moving on to the next
question in X asks where about in the
source code can i find that 4.1
lockscreen use cases to borrow the
layout aesthetics assets of the unlock
ring so I this is another one of those
questions that came in right before the
show so we haven't had a chance to look
at up yet that being said I want to say
that there's just if there's a package
called lock screen I think so it might
be a little off you know if you go to
store store intercom you can go to the
package viewer and find any oh just
search the page for lock and it'll come
up and I know it's in there but I can't
remember the exact package name off the
top of my head yeah I can try and
research it during the next question if
you have the if you have the Android
source downloaded already outside just
grep the source for lock screen you'll
be probably capital S or a capital L
capital S but i don't i don't know the
package off the top of my head we'd have
to look it up alright so let's go ahead
to next question Alex don't take this
one sure Oh what is the best view to use
to display an option between two items I
want the user to be able to select
between one-way and roundtrip the
available options don't seem to fit well
in my opinion what would you suggest
alright so you just want to go and have
like an option chooser basically like a
radio but just to select between two so
i guess the like what are the options we
have right now we have
the spinner which is a drop down and we
have radio buttons we also have I guess
tabs depending on how you would if it
would make sense in the context of your
app or you could put two buttons head by
side and make them you know you know
stay pressed right or you can have one
button that's a toggle button that just
changes the label of whatever action
it's going to perform it's really
difficult to say best one to use because
we have like we I mean we just iterated
over most of them then there are several
options and it very much depends on
context so being able to say okay so to
choose between one-way and roundtrip I
assume means something along the lines
of like buying airline tickets via
android app or something like that there
I would probably go with a drop down so
you don't take up too much of the screen
but yeah really is context dependent ok
I think I think I mean I think that's
pretty much you know that's pretty much
all the options I can think of off the
top of my head I mean it's tough to say
without actually seeing what your
applications doing yeah we can go ahead
and give you lots of very very general
advice but a screenshot would help
immensely here so if you happen to be
watching live feel free to hop on
google+ give us a little bit more
background about what you're doing and
we can go ahead and try and get you some
more tailored advice to your app failing
that there's also the Friday app clinic
or you can go ahead and get advice from
I believe rado and Ian are hosting that
right now really and then also there's
the UI share too what do you see why
show Monday 102 ok I think it's Monday
actually it's Tuesday it's Tuesday all
right yes uh I think it's quite if I
always the one side is probably has been
Tuesday oh and also for the one thing to
keep in mind for the Friday app clinic
the way that works is you submit your
app and usually you submit a link to it
on market or sorry I'm google play
market so
if the app isn't developed yet then that
wouldn't be a place for it in that case
you probably want to send a couple
screenshots to the UI review on Tuesday
but yeah I would say those are options
for follow-up but based on what i can
see of the one way versus round trip
seems like drop-down would be it would
not be a bad choice I don't know that
best choice I can say without looking at
your application right um yeah and I'm
just in here trying to find that lock
screen instead of package here but now I
think I think that's a good answer I
think that we without seeing the app now
I think we've said everything we can but
again if you're watching live we'd love
to get some more details and give you
some more tailored advice so let's move
on to that question Joe from Maine asks
I'm send ordered broadcasting wow so
verb now yeah I'm send order
broadcasting action media buttons and
then a button intense to media button
play pause I think there's the same
question we got to mimic a Bluetooth
button headset push or bluetooth headset
button push in android for and only or
android for it above only play music
response but pre-fall point out the
current music playing app would respond
what changed native for I think our
answer here is the same as last time we
got this question right before the show
so we don't know without actually
digging through the source which takes
us more than 10 minutes especially as
we're prepping for the show so
definitely good question i'd love to get
you an answer we just didn't have enough
time to answer it because this question
came in late we'll try and get you an
answer by next week's broadcast alright
so actually and this is actually pretty
good time to remind anyone who is
watching live feel free to join us on
google+ hangouts i assume that dan over
here in the corner is monitoring that so
if anybody does want to go and ask a
question just I guess either speak up or
you are watching the hangout right then
ok excellent yeah let's check there in
the corner yeah so if you do have a
question just wave your hand type
something a chat speak up we'll try and
get you on there live if you don't have
a microphone you can also go ahead and
type your questions to us in hangout
chat and we can read them out we'd love
to get live questions go easy on us yeah
can only do so much without actually
time to research stuff but yeah again
yeah questions like that last one on you
I excellent things that we'd love to
discuss live if anyone does want to go
over any that so let's see here this
question daniel says I understood you
wanted to look into last week's hgf to
the show edit text on unpause any news
on that one I don't think we have a
that's the is that the one that has to
do with the support library that's the
one or the value of the text box would
change when you rotated the device okay
so that it was pretty populated with
hello world hello world and you typed
zze in the values hello world zze then
you rotated the device the new value
just bzzz okay that one and it was a
it's an interesting quirk we haven't
actually had time to determine the cause
of that but we'll hopefully have time to
dig in yeah we should get you an answer
on that one by the end of the day yeah
alright so we actually have a screenshot
for the reservation Oh excellent awesome
are you able to put that up some way I
nobody take a look over my shoulder
right here okay so there's two buttons
is there any way for you to throw that
into the Hangout so that we're not just
a bunch of people staring off screen
into space um I had good load on the
hand computer yeah put on hang out
compete if you guys want all right yeah
let's just um so we'll get back to that
in a second 12 Dan Goossen and makes
that magically work for us alright so VD
asks consume you look at this issue on
the android bug tracker regarding the
broken clipboard on samsung's galaxy s3
so i did take a look at this and so the
issue in particular here is whenever the
user copies data into the clipboard on
that particular phone there's a crash
and that's not really a compatibility
issue per se i mean the api is still you
know the api hasn't changed any it's
more just an issue of general system
stability as far as i can tell yeah and
i'm not sure where exactly whether or
not that's issues because of a
modification that Samsung's made or if
it's a problem in the framework code
that said since it is a samsung devices
is only happening on my suspicion is
that there's some some interaction with
one of samsung's modifications or a
driver or something i think this is a
question we have to send over to samsung
and they'll have to address it's really
outside of our hands in that case i mean
like if it was a compatibility issue we
could update the the compatibility test
suite but this isn't this is just a more
an issue of the system is having some
some problem with the clipboard so
definitely a bug we'd like to look into
but it's one that Samsung is going to be
after responsible for fixing so that
being said now that you pointed out i'll
make sure that somebody attempts and
does see that so let's move on to the
next question I think Dan is still
working on that screen shot when a user
touches a list view item I would like to
hang a view off of the bottom of the
list view items such that it overlaps
the next list view item do you think
that this is possible and off the top of
your head any ideas on how you would do
it that's a tricky so I don't know if it
would necessarily be possible to alter
you babe basically you would have to
alter the Z value of so that it could
over so it sort of hang over the next
list view yeah but yeah I don't think
you'd be you want be able to do it as a
a you're part of the list view it have
to be another view that you stack on top
and in order to do that you'd have to go
to compute where the item is you know on
your screen and precisely position a
window there it's sort of painful I
think it's totally possible just go and
create a new view like Alex said you're
going to want to make sure that it's in
front of everything else and then just
set the XY coordinates that said I think
easier option would just be to go and
make your list view item a little bigger
yeah that's what i would do you still
have the effect of pushing it out of the
way I mean say it's not going over lap
right but it's going to slide the
options underneath that out of the way
and if you really wanted to you could
also maybe alter the like the the
brightness of the one below its and
above so that the other is around it
kind of frayed out now other thing to do
actually just insert another list view
item underneath it yeah you can also do
that yeah and in either case I'd make
sure you make take advantage the
animation framework there's a flag you
can set on the list for you to go and
make things nicely animate in and out
and that will get you some nice so nice
I can't need to go along with this
effect right I would if you're in the
Hangout I'd be curious why you're trying
to do this it's not really a behavior
that is a typical of a list view and it
might be kind of jarring I dance showing
us pictures or video feed of ourselves
starting to the abyss anyway it's not
something that's that's expected and I'd
be curious what the goal of that is if
it's just to command attention for one
list view item or to indicate it as
selected or something like that there
are other ways to accomplish that that
will require less coding on your part so
if David from Oakland if you're in the
Hangout or watching online just pop into
the Hangout and then I give us a little
bit more context and we can probably
answer your question a little better
right then do you have that screenshot
first ready yeah
okay so are you able to put that up life
not right okay yeah well we'll wait till
you have that live then okay well I want
to make sure our viewers can see what
what what we're looking at it so it's a
lot more interesting how okay otherwise
were just staring the box yeah all right
um let's move on to that question then
and this might actually be the last
recorded question so skate Benji from
Italy asks how do I get only the
contacts from the phone not facebook
contacts or gmail contacts I don't think
this is so well I I'm curious if this is
a developer question or a user question
because it let's take the user question
first if you're in the contacts app you
can on the latest version of Android
anyway you can go to the actual thing
yeah latest version you go to the
overflow menu old video persons you
click on the menu button and there's an
display options command I pulled up
actually i'll get you the exact value
but you can go ahead and click on that
and it'll let you pick which contacts
sources you want to go in sort so it's
basically a filter so I'll see here and
then basically it gives you the option
of oly displaying contacts with phone
numbers attached right so as a user
that's how you would do it so actually
it's called contacts display now I think
it used to be called display options
before and so I have a thing since all
contacts or Google and they list all my
google account so i can pick google plus
if i want to see my contacts from my my
Google+ circles if I had skype installed
Ocho my skype contacts and then there's
a customized option if you want to go
and get more specific and only select
certain groups things like that so
that's how the the People app or what
used to be known as the contacts app
handles it on older device or sorry up
on the API if you want to do this the
way this works for each if I remember
the contact schema correct layer for
each contact or each person you'll have
a overarching or overarching contact
entry and then link to that you'll have
a entry from each of the different
contact providers on your system so you
can go ahead and just construct a sequel
query that only gets contacts you know
from the from the package name that you
desire so if you you know con google
will show you all the googles
the context from google sources for
example or calm skype which are your
skype contacts and it's really just a
matter of selecting you know adding a
sequel where clause to only select that
packaging yeah i don't know what the
package name alpha gamma is i think its
combat google people for contacts yeah
yeah no contacts is con google okay so
but you explicitly say not gmail
contacts or i'm sailing you don't want
everyone in your buddy list because you
don't have their phone numbers so i
think it would actually a two-part
process where you search on the account
type being calm google and second of all
you would filter on making sure that the
phone number is is not null and actually
as a value life yeah that I'd be a
little careful about this because some
phones will let you pick without you
want to save the contact of the sim card
or to google contacts that being said
most most of the Google you know the
Nexus devices will only save contacts to
google contacts at least you know for
new contacts that you create unless you
have some other contact provider
installed enforce it is modular but the
default behavior is only to use google
contacts and the reason we do that is
because we want to go and make sure
everything is synced to the cloud it
gives users a really nice experience
right whatever new phone you get all
your contacts are right there so if you
decide that you want to filter out gmail
contacts you might be file turing out
every single contact the user has on
their phone so i think really you if you
do want to add some filtering here I
think you'd be wise to go and mimic the
behavior of the of the People app and
give the user a choice which contact
sources do they want to display rather
than just saying I only want to show
contacts that are on the sim card
because actually I'd say on most devices
out there that's going to get you into
trouble and you're going to filter out
most contacts yeah all right any luck
Tin give me one second out for the on
screen and
okay let me go guys so we're going to be
the ringing you I review to wednesday
right now it's true okay so yeah so in
this case the other there's a spinner on
top that says one way and then
underneath that what's the text over
there say this is a to the airport ah
and then there's a button that says it's
green cheese flight time okay gotcha so
it's like a say directions they're porn
app I imagine okay yeah so yeah first
thing I do you that spin are actually
pretty bad oh I'm not a fan of that
spinner I think your best option here is
look at the way google maps doesn't
right you have a you have buttons there
for you know one way around trip yeah I
wouldn't use a tab by or or use a
coaster called rodeo your radio buttons
would work view pager some lasting a
tabs in few pages I leave off the table
I think that's even more heavy-handed
than the spinner is right now yeah tabs
and view pager should only really be
used when the when each option would
then have it would then change the
entire UI in terms of what other options
you were presenting yeah now I mean the
spinner that you have it right now isn't
terribly bad the problem is it's just
too wide you're using up the entire with
your page but even then let's say we do
make it smaller and make that make
things a little more streamlined their
problem you're going to run into here is
that it's multiple clicks to pick what
type of of Transportation you want right
it's at least two clicks probably
actually almost exclusively two clicks
you're going to click on the spinner and
you're going to click on the other
option and you really just don't have
enough choices here to go and justify
the overhead of a full spinner it's
really just you know option one or
option two and so this is where radio
buttons or a toggle switch which we if
you'd implement just as two buttons
side-by-side would really come
Andy yeah yeah yeah I think this is
definitely a good one to bring up for
you for as an example in Roman co2 but
yeah I think I think that pretty much
answers the question of what's the best
way to do this if you do have any more
questions again feel free to pop on a
pop on to hang out if anybody on hang
out right now is any questions I think
now's the time to speak up we are at the
end of our pre submitted questions today
so if nobody else has knee questions
anybody setting on their nope all right
we actually have 11 unrelated question
oh let's take it where where's the
TARDIS which is I guess of reference to
Doctor Who yeah well I it's up on the
shelf oh yeah the answer is it's still
there they're just right off cameras
like off camera it's to its up and to
the Agra Sox's on the right on your on
your screen yes I've been to the right
behind alex's head and you can take a
little green android there and the red
android jellybean jar just to the right
of it it's right next to the jellybean
jar it's and we are still there we had a
time machine question we didn't even
have a TARDIS on yeah it's still broken
still doesn't go through time we still
can't answer those questions that were
paralyzed right now yeah but now it's
still there as soon as we get it fixed
we'd love to answer your questions about
the feature but somehow I don't think we
have any time lords on staff it's a sure
it is we keep trying to hire them but
but no one ever takes the gig well we
have trouble getting in touch with them
they keep floating around through time
but anyway I think that's all the time
we have today for questions given the
drought of questions so if you do have
your quite any questions for next week
you'll be sure to hop onto Google
moderator and submit them ahead of time
the earlier you submit them the better
answers we can give you will be usually
reset moderator about an hour or two
after the show end so if you're watching
this pre-recording this live wait a
little bit if you're watching the
recorded version is probably already up
right now you can access the moderator
for a page by going to either our Plus
page developer.android.com / + or going
to searching for Google developers live
and
accessing our page from the Google
developers live homepage so with that
said I think it's time to say goodbye
for this week yeah good motor for this
week yep all right and again we're on
everyone's day 2 p.m. pacific send us
your android questions and we'll answer
them for you right see everyone goes